star trek card season two started so
promisingly
but i've just watched episode seven and
eight
and i'm not even going to bother getting
the green screen out it doesn't really
deserve it
welcome to star trek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
[Music]
so yeah um i've been away for the week
and i'm full of cold
um but i still watched star trek today i
watched picard um episode 78 monsters
and um and episode eight
and they are
pretty bad
i've got some major problems with this
series
the thing is actually the production
value is very high
it's beautifully made
we have canon ships back
we have a few little nods to things like
uh the voyage home which i really
enjoyed
the acting's good
the dialogue is actually pretty good the
writing isn't
terrible even though the story is pretty
bad
but there are a few things that i just
cannot forgive and most of them happen
in episode seven
it's not logical it doesn't make any
sense so right two things
captain rios
seems to have forgotten what the prime
directive is the most important law for
any federation crew member and he's a
captain don't forget
the temporal prime directive same thing
most important law they have it's
enshrined in what is the federation
he just seems to don't give a crap he's
horny he likes that girl so he's just
like prime directive prime there i don't
care i'm just gonna beam you guys aboard
this ship
now i know this is building up towards
him probably staying in the past
but why are they doing it this way
why are they doing it in such an
illogical way
and then
picard has his lie down
which i actually think a lot of this
series is written in a way to allow
picard to sit or lie down
i think patrick stewart is very unwell i
don't think his mobility is great and i
actually think they've had to write
scenes or entire episodes which allow
him to sit as much as possible and i'm
not being mean about that it's genuinely
the only thing that makes sense to me
um
but
through
no logical sense he figures out that q
is responsible for all this and actually
everything that's going on is maybe more
about q than he realized
um
so he goes back to gaiden and gaining
spends what felt like three or four
hours explaining to us that there's this
magic genie bottle
and if she drinks from it and then
starts talking what sounds like parcel
tongue
and
then everything starts shaking and stuff
then she can summon a cue right now she
doesn't say the cue john de lancie's cue
specific or you know a specific you just
summon a queue
it doesn't work
john delancey is sick he has to walk
there apparently we find out in episode
eight so that's why it takes long to get
there
um but
why didn't another q come
again there's no logical sense to this
it shouldn't have been it's not like the
nearest queue it's not like all the
other queue would go in there john's got
that
why
did they ignore this like forbidden
summoning thing and why did the rest of
them just ignore it and only john
delance is there going oh bloody i'm
gonna have to walk there no i'm gonna
feel the bus
um it's just a joke
another thing i hate about card series
two so far is that we've barely seen q
in it he's the best thing in it i always
wondered why why did they never do like
a spin-off series of q john de lancie is
the is one of the greatest star trek
actors ever his character is fantastic
i'd love to see
um what they should do is the series of
him like um solving crimes in los
angeles that'd be great um be sarcastic
don't do that um i wouldn't put anything
past this series actually started like
alex kurtzman please don't listen to the
idea it's not a genuine idea
um
but they could have done a q series i
think would have been pretty cool um but
john de lancie has been woefully
underused in this series we're getting a
lot of brent spiner which i love even
though that story line is so far
completely irrelevant but seems to be
building towards something
um we have several other storylines that
are completely irrelevant like the
entire thing about meeting his dad
completely relevant to the actual story
we learned a little bit more about
picard i suppose but not really
um but john delancey should be in this
series far more than he is the whole
thing about him dying and like it's not
as much fun as i thought it would be
why did they do that in this episode in
like two minutes they could that could
have been a really really cool build up
to that and they just didn't bother they
hinted it a little bit i suppose in the
first couple of episodes but then they
just sort of went well like i'm done
great scene actually most by far the
most interesting thing in the entire
series um but they put it in like two
seconds at the end
just
um
there's lots of things about the series
that are actually really really good
though the parts
seem to be good the production value
really high beautifully made the acting
really good um even though a lot of the
characters are quite forgettable the
dialogue is good even though the story
is illogical
the story
on the whole is brilliant i love the
ball coming back from the first series
you know and you know in the first
episode sorry all of that really really
interesting but together
they just don't work
how often do we hear something is
greater than some of its parts
picard series two is the opposite it's
less than the sum of its parts it's
they've got all these great ingredients
to bake an amazing cake
and
they've made a massive pile of poop
and i don't really know how it's
happened
but
guys you get into the comments you tell
me what you think because this is just a
quick video for me
i actually generally don't think it's
worth me even getting my tripod out
to to to you know to do a proper video
and i'm definitely not getting the
screen screen out to do it um
i'm so disappointed by picard series 2
now
i might be saying goodbye to star trek
and that for me is just insane because
i'm i'm a trekkie i'm a complete trekkie
i am this close to giving up on star
trek
but guys get in the comments tell me
what you think how you enjoying picard
series two do you think they can pull it
out of the bag at the end you know that
we're going to get a finale that
actually makes this worthwhile i think
we're not going to get a finale series
and two i think it's just going to bleed
into series 3 but let's find out
do you think john de lancie should be
used more than he is being personally i
think that's a no-brainer
and you know
are we going to get a lot more scenes
where basically it's just there to like
hard to sit down for a bit
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification don't have too many hate
comments this is just my opinion if you
like the show then brilliant i'm really
happy and yes i know i keep shaking a
little bit but um i'm not well so
yeah
also if you would like to become a fully
fledged side tracker you can hit the
join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you